thank you all very much for coming along
this afternoon I think I'm going to take
some questions from the media there they
are
there they've been patiently patiently
waiting at the back I'm going to go to
to Andy Bell of Channel five and then
Paul brand of my TV Andy you that yeah
I'm here if I Minister hello Thank You
Prime Minister um aren't people entitled
to ask if your own brother can't back
you why should anyone else well actually
my own brother as you all have seen from
what he said and stuff no no first of
all I want to pay great tribute and he's
asking about my brother Joe who is a
fantastic guy and was a brilliant
Minister for for science for
universities did a fantastic amount of
good work for us for this country in
that area now Joe doesn't agree with me
about the European Union because it's a
it's an issue that obviously divides
families and divides everybody but I
think what Joe would agree is that we
need to get on and sort this thing out
and I think what Joe certainly would
agree and I think he does um he said as
much this afternoon is that this
government has exactly the right
priorities when it comes to dealing with
the issues that really matter to the
British people I'm talking about making
our streets safer I'm talking about
improving our hospitals and improving
our education service so I thank Joe for
all the work that he's done and for the
support that he's given for our domestic
agenda and I'm gonna go now to pour
brand of my TV Thank You Prime Minister
Prime Minister if your own brother has
lost faith in your related topic Prime
Minister but but but a different
question if your own brother has lost
faith in your plan surely you'll have to
be the next member of the Dom's and
family to resign well my intention as I
said just now and I'm absolutely
determined to do this is to deliver on
the mandate of the people though we have
a democracy in this country
and the way we work is that when the
people of Britain take a decision
parliamentarians are sworn to uphold
that decision and that's what we all
said we would do several times in the
House of Commons to respect the result
of the 2016 referendum on the EU and
people voted by a very substantial
majority to leave we all said we would
we would do it and that is what I want
to do and I have to say I think there is
a stark contrast between my approach and
I I hate to be party political but it
that is the sad reality the approach of
of Jeremy Corbyn and the Labour Party
because at the moment he won't hear not
not only are they voting to make it
impossible for this country to decide on
its own to to leave the EU but they're
also making it possible for the people
of this country to have a an election
and I think he must be the first leader
of the Opposition in history to refuse
to have an election in fact it seems to
me to be a breach of his of his job
description
he's part of the Opposition he should be
he should be actively seeking election I
didn't think I've ever seen anything
like it but my job is to get us out on
October the 31st and that is what we're
gonna do Beth Ruby's going Thank You mr.
Johnson when you became Prime Minister
you said you wouldn't unite our country
instead you'll split in your party and
now even your own brother feels he
cannot serve under you if your own
brother doesn't trust you to act in the
national interest why should all of we
well as you'll have seen what Joe had to
say about our agenda and he's a strong
look people disagree about the EU but
the way to unite the country I'm afraid
is to get this thing done that is the
reality the longer this goes on the more
dither and delay we have from from
Parliament inspired I'm afraid by Jeremy
Corbyn the worse this thing will be what
people want to see is a resolution and
they want to see us getting this thing
done
and that's what we're going to do